et pour finir notre belle belle rubrique
Sport côté invité nous allons parler
avec Claude degren donc président du du
club de de plongé de de 50 ans en ieline
parce que ce club là fait ses 30 ans et
oui cette semaine et oui la semaine
prochaine le 20 octobre précisément à la
salle des fêtes de mPas donc on va
inviter les anciens les nouveaux tout le
monde dans une joyeuse fête pour parler
un petit peu de la plongée de son
évolution l'évolution du club aussi bien
sûr et alors justement les évolution du
club 30 ans c'est long dans dans
l'histoire d'un club il y a eu des des
étapes un peu charnières la création
peut-être des évolutions derrière alors
oui la création c'était une étape
charnière puisque c'était la plongée
était mélangée avec le club de nage à
l'époque et puis en 82 et bien il y a
une cission pour créer un vrai club de
plongée à part entière ce qui lui a
permis bah d'acquérir du
matériel des cadres et puis faire de la
formation et continuer jusqu'à
maintenant et c'est plongé avec ou sans
bouteille alors au début c'était la
plongée avec bouteille essentiellement
et surtout de la nage avec palme et puis
ça s'est traduit par aussi d'autres
activités fédérales tes que le tir sur
cible tel que l'apné voilà plein de
choses l' je POS cette question
précisément sur l'aspect peut-être plus
technique parce qu'en 30 ans on imagine
aussi que les techniques ont évolué ça a
fait évoluer la pratique de de votre
discipline alors les techniques ont
évolué et aussi la technique c'estàd le
matériel ça qui a beaucoup apportter
pour pouvoir faire faire de la plongée à
des jeunes avec du matériel plus léger
plus plus adapté et aussi pour les
femmes puisque il y a quelques années
les femmes devaient se contenter du
matériel homme et maintenant c'est
matériel adapté dans on voit les photos
un peu de de
l'évolution du club et des techniques
voilà là ça c'est vieux 100 km de la
Loire puis qu'il y a aussi de la nage
avec palme sur 100 km on passe une
journée dans l'eau c'est compliqué les
moyens techniques ont évolué mais les
attentes des pratiquants ont peut-être
aussi changé non oui oui il y avait il y
a quelques années il y a 30 ans vraiment
un bénévolat un plaisir de faire les
choses or maintenant pour raccourcir
c'est pas tout à fait vrai mais c'est
plutôt de la consommation on vient
consommer une année de de de sport parce
que bah on n pas trouvé autre chose dans
le créneau qui nous plaît et puis on
prend ça parce que voilà c'est un peu
dans tous les clubs ouais ouai oui mais
ça ça représente à côté pour toutit
d'accord avec ce faut pas généraliser
non PE et alors au sein de du club de
Saint-Quentin il y a sûrement des des
des gens de loisirs des pratiquants
loisirs mais aussi du du très bon niveau
voilà il y a a un peu tout il y a de
l'entretien les gens viennent pour
entretenir dans un sport qui qui leur
plaît et puis aussi il y a du haut
niveau alors dans la plongée il y a pas
de haut niveau parce que c'est pas un
sport de compétition on va dire ça comme
ça sport de haut niveau au niveau de la
nage avec palme donc là oui il a il y a
il y a des très beaux compétiteurs au
niveau du tir surour cile je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler un peu
tout à l'heure et puis de l'apnée où là
effectivement c'est un sport de
compétition à part entière et justement
ce weekend il y a un très beau trophée
le trophée Galiero le compte qui qui
arrive bien avec avec l'anniversaire
tout à fait dimanche c'est les 30 ans du
non c'est pas les 30 ans c'est 30 ans du
club mais c'est la compétition de tir
sur cible qu'on appelle le trophée
Galiero le compte qui rend hommage à des
gens qui sont encore vivants c'est peu
fréquent et ils en sont très contents
d'ailleurs ils ont été longtemps des
gens de du club des moniteurs des
encadrants et des compétiteurs de haut
niveau puisque jusqu'au Championnat du
Monde en Russie et donc on leur fait
honneur en ayant créé ce trophée et qui
est une mange de la Coupe de France qui
fait partie du circuit et à l'heure
actuelle les structures comment ça se
passe parce que pour la plongé il faut
de la place une piscine ça suffit pas il
faut pas que seulement qu'une piscine de
25 m j'imagine alors comment je vais
vous dire ça on a de la place mais pas
suffisamment c'est clair surtout en
créneau mais il y a tellement peu de
piscine et tellement de monde qui
veulent jouer dans les piscines que bah
voilà c'est pas facile à résoudre donc
nous nos créneaux c'est le soir parce
qu'on est plutôt adulte on aimerait bien
des créneaux un petit peu différent pour
accueillir les jeunes par qu'on ne peut
pas accueillir de jeunes parce qu'on a
pas de créneau mais bon ça c'est un
problème L à la piscine mais en tout cas
le club fête donc ces 30 ans une
manifestation ouverte au public vous
allez fêter ça avec le public ou pas 30
alors le public peut venir au moins à
l'apppéritif de bienvenue à partir de
18h à la salle des fêtes de M repas et
puis après vers 20h 20h30 il y aura le
dîner de gala qui là plutôt
rés aux gens qui ont qui sont venus
depuis longemps qui ont construit ce
club qui fait donc ces 30 ans merci
d'être venu en plateau merci également
au club de triathlon de C quen1 et on
finit la page sport forcément avec des
résultats avec des résultats tout
d'abord du basket euh l'Entente Sportive
des des cheminaux de trappe débloque
enfin son compteur victoire les
Trappistes sont allés s'imposer ce
weekend sur le parquet de tourcoin sur
le score de 72 à 60 de quoi se donner un
peu d'air après le l'incident de la
semaine dernière dont on avait on avait
parlé sur sur le plateau au cours du
match au gymnase Paul maillet face à
Berk dossier sur lequel la Fédération
n'a toujours pas statué il certains
spectateurs on va les appeler comme ça
qui avait ouvert des des des pseudo
supporters qui sont venus qui ont un peu
vidé un extincteur dans les tribunes
interruption de match et la Fédération
n'a pas tranché la suite des résultats
du football oui football les féminines
de Montini on continue à les suivre
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué pour
lors de cette 4e journée elles ont
résisté très très longtemps les
inimontaines aux assauts du leader etin
Bobon mais dans les dernières minutes
elles se sont inclinées sur un sur un
but de de marine daffer les inimonages
pointent désormais à la 9e place de de
Division 2 à 10 points de leur
adversaire du weekend mais elles ont
encore un match de retard donc tout est
possible pour pour raccrocher au bon
wagon c'est toujours du sport féminin
c'est toujours un Montil mais c'est du H
ball cette fois-ci c'est du H ball oui
mais pas une bonne nouvelle hein pour
pour les joueus de de Montini la marche
était un peu trop haute pour ce 3e tour
de Coupe de France face à Octeville sur
mer les joueuses de Stéphane paysan
n'ont rien pu faire défaites 34 à 19
malgré une belle résistance et et un
beau match c'était trop compliqué deux
divisions dessus le petit Pousset n'a
pas pu faire grand-chose des fait
logique et anticipé hein par
l'entraîneur qui était sur le plateau
aussi la semaine dernière et n l'avait
dit pas s'attendre à un exploit non plus
et puis du roll roqu pour finir
exactement leur Requet les chocks
continuent leur belle lancée après la
première journée et leur première
victoire une seconde consécutive face à
maison la fite ce weekend les chocs se
sont imposés sur le score de tris buts à
de malgré une très très belle
performance du du gardien adverse et une
défense plutôt regroupé les joueurs des
lancours sont coleader National 3 à
égalité avec Aubergenville merci Anthony
prochain point complet sur le sport
lundi prochain à la même heure et juste
pour conclure vous avez décidé de nous
emmener sur les pistes de BMX de 50 ans
oui on va rouler on va faire de la bosse
le club de BMX organisait ce weekend le
CH une manche du championnat régional
élite et et amateur et il y a une
nouvelle mode sur les pistes de de BMX
c'est que les papas font du du vélo avec
leurs enfants reportage d'Alice Gastine
et David
charpentier un père son fils toutous
deux passionné de BMX et un même
objectif se faire plaisir tous les
samedis à l'entraînement sur la piste de
voisin le Bretonneux en fait je suis
passionné de VTT depuis 20 ans
maintenant et je me suis toujours dit
que j'aimerais bien faire du BMX donc
j'ai attendu que mon fils ait l'âge qu'
soit apte physiquement selon moi et donc
nous sommes inscrits il y a maintenant 3
ans qui est le meilleur pilote alors
pour l'instant j'ai encore un peu
d'avance mais je pense que d'ici 2 3 ans
normalement si l'évolution enfin s'il
continue à faire du BMX ça devrait
s'inverser assez rapidement comme il le
disait c'est pour l'instant c'est lui
qui est le plus cass cou ah oui j'aime
bien le lancer quand même
parce que sinon si je reste comme ça ça
ça va rien faire plus cass cou non je
pense que on n'est pas casscou ni l'un
ni l'autre qui est le plus assidu
pendant les entraînements oh c'est
pareil oui oui niveau assiduité tant
qu'il y a un entraîneur qui qui dicte un
peu les les conduites et les exercices à
faire on est on est là on est présent on
n'est pas on se cache
pas je sais pas l'aventure familiale ne
s'arrête pas là puisque petit frère de
Tho Sacha 6 ans et demi a rejoint la
tribu BMX cette année on trouve en
famille c'est toujours bien de faire
apprendre à son petit frère et de
transmettre
quoi